fraud falsifying financial documents and
money laundering
all of this at a tax listed company last
june the dealings at wire card came to
light
the german payment service provider went
bankrupt after executives admitted that
almost 2 billion euros in assets were
likely non-existent
since then many have been asking how
could this have been
happened today a parliamentary inquiry
committee is presenting
some of their findings
to the outside world it was a successful
dax group
but in reality it was riddled with fraud
behind a clean facade
criminals were at work former ceo
marcus braun is currently in custody
ex-asia board member jan marzilek is a
fugitive
wirecard was once an electronics
payments service provider
and even operated a bank in germany
but it turns out some sales were
completely made up
the balance sheet showed a 1.9 billion
euro
hole since then public prosecutors began
investigating the company on commercial
fraud and document falsification charges
there had been rumors for years media
outlets repeatedly reported
inconsistencies
but each year the ey auditing firm gave
wirecard a seal of approval
the german financial regulator bob finn
didn't investigate the allegations
either quite the opposite journalists
who reported on fraudulent dealings at
wire card
received complaints
since october a parliamentary
investigative committee
has been scrutinizing the role of the
authorities in this scandal
but one thing is certain germany's
financial supervisors are ready for
reforms
one of the heads of this enquirer
committee is fabio dimazi he's a member
of the german parliament the bundestag
for the left party and he joins me now
welcome to dw
fabia what is your most important
finding in this investigation so far
well our most important finding is that
um
multiple state agencies failed to do
their job properly while there were
individuals that
had warned those agencies so there was a
kind of
collective attitude on to
to close close eyes and we also
found that the german government was
quite active actually in china
in the context of the german chinese
financial dialogue
to lobby for wirecard a lot of political
personalities had been
lobbying for wirecard and just to give
you one example
some of the supervisors that were
supposed
to ask tough questions on wirecard
were actually trading in wirecard shares
um instead of doing their job
so do you think that is one of the
biggest problems here that
state actors have been financially
involved
when owning wire carters
well that's part of the story that some
people
in the supervision agencies were trading
in those stocks
and that we didn't have proper rules in
germany in place to prevent this kind of
insider trading for example in the
financial
supervision authority but on the other
hand
we know that all those decisions that
have been taken like the
short selling ban on wirecut were
approved
by the ministry or at least have been
notified in the german ministry of
finance
so there's also the question on
political responsibilities and it was
chancellor merkel who indeed lobbied the
most powerful man
in china for wirecard and you do not
simply
go to china just because her former
economic minister gutenberg who was a
lobbyist for wirecard
told her so but this was a decision that
had been taken
in the german government because like
wirecard was one of the key assets
in a german chinese financial dialogue
and so
the german government has to answer why
they did not
react to the reporting of the financial
times
so this report or the scandal rather has
moved germany's federal financial
watchdog into the crosshairs it has a
staff of
2 700 but reportedly there are only five
people
who are licensed auditors do you see
signs that the overhaul
of the watchdog as a result of the
scandal are going into the right
direction
well we have some minor improvements now
for example we had a two-tier approach
so first we had a
kind of like um privately governed
organization that was supposed
to check balance sheets and they had
also multiple conflict of
interests but for example the so-called
dpr
which comes prior to the financial
supervision watchdog buffon when it
comes to
to checking the accuracy of balance
sheets they
actually asked even wirecard to equip
them with arguments why they should not
investigate fraud so you could see
a lot of collusion of interests here but
indeed the problem is the primary
problem is
that the german financial supervision
authority only has those five people
um who are even able to to to audit
companies
and that's insane that's like uh if the
german police
would basically go to the formula one or
to the
oktoberfest and bavara and tell them to
examine
you know like alcohol controls um on
on german roads uh that's that's not
possible
and so you need a state agency that is
able to do its job it needs the best
people in the market and it needs tough
people who ask the right questions
fabio damasi member of the parliamentary
inquiry committee under the wire cart
scandal
thank you for your thoughts
you